[Music]
honey mama what is it I have to go with
Roy
I was told to take a man to hotel I said
that he was an enemy of the state take
off your dress
and in exchange my mother look at the
doctor she needed instead they cut his
throat
there could be no witnesses so there
could be a choice die or become a
sparrow from this day forward you will
become spouse weapons in a global
struggle for power you'll be trained to
be psychological manipulation you must
learn to push yourself beyond all
limitation take off your clothes when we
are finished with you
the person you were will no longer exist
every human being is a puzzle of need we
must become the missing piece and they
will tell you anything you have a gift
you know how to survive this is what you
were meant
who's the traitor and the government his
last known contact is an American did
close I'm a very simple yesterday are we
going to become friends is that what you
want just Pharaoh the only matter cause
of what you can do for them work with me
and make these men pay you are better
this than any of us your only problem is
you have a soul
we can't trust a word that comes out of
her mouth there's something else we're
now seeing
if she's compromised she will be
eliminated what have you done
you belong to them they won't ever let
go I'll find a way
let me just break it down for you the
whole time you're rooting for this
Hemingway guy who survived the war and
to be with the woman that he loves like
clocking out why can't somebody say hey
let's have a good ending to the story I
can't apologize you know what I will do
I will apologize on behalf of Ernest
Hemingway does that suze the blame here
you have Ernest Hemingway call us and
apologize to us - what are you gonna do
with yourself getting shrimp getting
really fit for Nicky Patrick's she left
she's gone doc I had one incident I come
home from work I see my wife in the
shower I pull the curtain back so yeah I
stopped Hey this is Pat you look nice
thank you I'm not flirting with you I
didn't think you were look I think
you're really pretty I'm married okay
oh my no that's confusing he's dead wait
what's happening
there's a fan oh what's this I hear but
you're just getting out of the loony bag
I thought you said you had it together
you were solid I am solid I was solid at
the game
I just want us to be friends so how'd
you lose your job I having sex with
everybody in the office everybody was
very depressed after Tommy died we don't
have to talk about thanks how many were
there
don't let Tiffany get you in trouble
she's my friend why would you say that
there's this dance thing I can only do
it if I have a partner I'm not gonna
dance with you
so is this the girl you wrote about you
wrote about me she's fun she is my
friend with an F in capital down this is
poor friend let me tell you about pay
attention to signs when life reaches out
at a moment like this it's a sin if you
don't reach back on the talents or
sinned if you don't reach back this is
what I believe to be true you have to do
everything you can you have to work your
hardest if you stay positive you have a
shot at a silver lining hey what's this
well I thought you were doing I thought
you were doing it we could do what you
know take off living the woods
they'd catch us maybe not we wouldn't
make it five miles
[Music]
[Music]
welcome the time has come to select one
courageous young man and woman for the
honor of representing district 12 in the
74th annual Hunger Games two first year
prim names and even under once
Connecticut
[Music]
every
I volunteer as tribute
they just want a good show that's all
they want
it's 24 of us Gale only one comes out
[Music]
to make me look pretty it'd help you
make an impression
and so it was decreed that each year the
twelve districts of Panem shall offer up
in tribute one young man and woman
between the ages of 12 and 18 to be
trained in the art of survival is to be
prepared the fight took a desert this is
the time to show them everything make
sure they remember you guys keep wishing
I could think of a way to show that that
they don't own me if I'm gonna die I
want to still be me I just can't afford
to think like that
[Music]
four three two one
[Music]
hello he asking me on a date
she didn't seem that impressed you clean
up pretty good herself did she looked
famous Eton we're on a date very nice
took you long enough to ask so why did
you give up your life on her he boarded
the Avalon
destination 120 years hibernation means
a wake up in a new century on a new
planet but a year ago everything changed
do you know what's going on but nobody
else is awake I think something went
wrong with the hibernation box
we woke up too soon 90 years too soon
nice kami go back to sleep
something's wrong something big
what do we do now
do you trust me
[Music]
this ship is gonna go
[Music]
that's something I have to tell you
there's a reason we woke up early
[Music]
what's the last thing you remember
I glimpse into the past
[Music]
you've come to have to do for me what I
wanted for you
you'll need me as well
[Music]
side-by-side to mend this wall
before it ever begins
so wake up my young body and my find me
convince me all of this it's good to
take the Turks then where do I find you
well different paths at darker path
Logan I was a very different man
believe me
guy
[Music]
take patient with me
[Music]
patience isn't my strongest suit
I don't want to suffering
and of what your future
please we need you to hope again
[Music]
I want to show you something this
Rembrandt here you can come from all
over the world to see this yeah he's
good yeah what you see that's impossible
people believe what they want to believe
he's the guy who made this was so good
that is real to everybody
notice the master the painter or the
forger
[Music]
[Music]
toast to a new era
[Music]
I never took a quarter for my phone
booth you stole
I just got bigger Boston you listen to
me I'll tell you what's gonna come of
you you are going to grow up and be a
strong smart young woman go to school be
a fine young man have beautiful children
of your own and you're gonna build
wonderful things and that is what it's
going to happen to you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
don't ever think that the world owes you
anything because it doesn't
[Music]
[Music]
my name's joy by the way
[Music]
what are you came to say hello hello
George Benedict
Serena Shaw I think we should be married
[Music]
never thought I'd find you
I never thought I'd find anyone that's
beautiful George and that's justice done
can you find a wife or a partner well
well letter came from the bank I'm
afraid your stocks are no longer
sufficient collateral
he took the washes he can destroy us
George
you're gonna go to prison our future
everything that we talked about we will
lose it if we promise to tell each other
everything I didn't want frightened you
I'm not that kind of woman
don't forget about everything but each
other
I'm doing this for us joining our new
world plays hockey I'd like to speak to
your wife there's a murder last night
[Music]
he betrayed you George he was never your
friend our love began the day we met
nothing that happened before even exists
this is everything you need to put me
away forever I love you so much I can't
lose you you are
you'd have to be done
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
disgusting I'm looking for this is she
here I don't know I wouldn't be angry if
she's here
promise me you won't tell you what about
Karia yeah listen we have a new neighbor
okay my name is ELISA her mom just moved
in I want you to leave her alone
understand me what exactly happen again
your daughter and carrion killed both
your parents you know that house is the
reason why we can't even afford to rent
this house really double murder
[Music]
I think this place is gonna be really
good for us
[Music]